يعني فينا فينا نعمل المقاربه انه التاريخ
هو يمشي بنفس السرعه وبعد بعد هذا القطار
ما وصل لعنا هذا القطار التغيير اذا اذا
فينا نسمي بعرف اذا المقارنه مع اوروبا
يعني مفيده بهالمعنى يعني المقارنه مع
اوروبا
الاوروبا كان في وجهه صحيح
القصه اخذت مئه سنين
وصارت حروب وصار كذا بس كان في وجهه ممكن
تلمسها باستمرار في وجهات محور ذات مره
حول التنوير حول النهضه حول الثوره
الصناعيه حول الثوره السياسيه
لاحقا حول العولم الى اخره نحن ما في وجهه
عنا حاليا ما في وجهه ما في شيء فيك ترزه
الان يعني تقول انا رايي الفرصه الوحيده
اللي اتيحت
هي بعد انهيار السلطن العثمانيه مباشره
بعد انهيار السطل العثمانيه حصل انتدبين
على منطقه المشرق العربي على الاقل انت
تبان الفرنسي والبريطاني ما حدا بيحب انه
ينتذب عليه او انه يستعمر بالتاكيد لكن
قياسات
بمكان قبلا وما حصل بعد
حصلت شغله فينا نسميها فرصه هالفرصه
ترافات مع
الاستعانه باعيام محليين للحكم هني فيما
بعد تولوا الحكم بعد الاستقلالات ترافات
مع
مثل ما كلمه انتداب يعني بتقول مع بناء
شويه احزاب اعلام
نقابات صحف
فتنه فيها على ادوات العالم الحديث وهي
الفرصه كان ممكن وكان نظري كمان
في حياه سقفيه معقوله وكان فيني اشهد
ونقاشات فعلا يعني حاره يعني مثل موضوع طه
حسين الشعب الجاهلي او علي عبد الرازق
هدول امكن خوض هالمعاركه الفكريه الكبيره
دون ما حدا ما حدا قتلوه صح حسين ولا حدا
سجن ولا على يعني اخر امر مش بس هيك بعد
سنوات رجعوا وزروهم صاروا وزراء يعني
بكثير من العيوب والنواقص والقصور والى
اخره بس اللي صار مره اخرى
انه
هالممانعه للفوت
بفكره الدوله للعالم الجديد اذا الدوله
الحديثه اذا بدك نعم هل ممانعه اللي هي
مسكونه بروحها
بوعي سلطان بوعي امبراطوره ما له راحت
السلطنه العثمانيه ربما تستانف بسلطنه
عربيه امبراطوريه عربيه يعني كان دائما في
هيك هل الطموح الطموح هذا من جهه عبر عنه
شيبه الحركه الاخوان المسلمين مبكرا ب 28
بعدين حركه القوميه مثل البعث
حركه القوميه العرب الى اخره
الانظمه العسكريه والامنيه لتحولوا
لاجيولوجيه
تستقطب فيها الناس او تبرر حاله فيها
وطبعا طبعا اللي زاد الطين بلي وجعل
الاوضاع يعني اصعب اكثر هو نشاه اسرائيل
يعني نكبه فلسطين ب 48
اعطت هالكلام سوء نعم بانه كثير التجارب
اللي بتقول انه موضوع فلسطين هالقد استعمل
كذا ريعه لشيء ما كثير الو على فلسطين
ولم يزل طبعا ولماذا اكثر لان على اكثر
بكثير
صار السقف على اكبر واخطر واكثر كلفه اخطر
لانه عنده لباس مذهبي وطائفي
طبعا ولانه ولانه فعلا لانه فعلا ايران
يعني بتجارب المنطقه
تجربتين كبار
مشكلتهم مش بس انه النظام السياسي سيء
وشقدر انه هن عم يغيروا الطبيعه اول
محاوله لتغيير الطبيعه كانت دوله اسرائيل
دوله اسرائيل اجت اقابت شيله شعب محله
وجابت شعب محله اخر قعد هذا تغيير اساسي
للطبيعه
المحاوله الثاني نظام الايراني نظام
الخميني يلي بده يتجاوز حدود
وبلدان من العراق لسوريا للبنان لفلسطين
ايضا
في تغيير للطبيعه والتاني اخطر من الاول
لسبب بسيط الفرق السكاني والجغرافي
بيجعل التمدديه او الترشعيه الايرانيه
اكثر
حضورا وتاثيرا